I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们要为你专门制作一档终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。
Hello. Hey lady. I'm excited today. I am so excited. We're the office ladies. Hello. Hey, lady. I'm excited today. I am so excited. We get to share our interview with a very special guest. Bob Odenkirk. Yes. He comes in the studio with us.
你好。嗨，女士。我今天很兴奋。我太兴奋了。我们是办公室女士。你好。嗨，女士。我今天很兴奋。我太兴奋了。我们有机会分享对一位非常特殊嘉宾的采访。鲍勃·奥登科克。是的。他来到了我们的录音室。
For a very long chat. I know. Well, you know, Bob is probably best known for playing lawyer Saul Goodman on Breaking Bad and Better Call Saul. And in the world of the office, he's been a very special guest. He's been a very special guest. He's been a very special guest. He's been a very special guest.
进行了一场非常长的聊天。我知道。嗯，你知道，鲍勃最著名的角色可能是在《绝命毒师》和《风骚律师》中饰演律师索尔·古德曼。在《办公室》的世界里，他是一位非常特殊的嘉宾。他是一位非常特殊的嘉宾。他是一位非常特殊的嘉宾。他是一位非常特殊的嘉宾。
He's been a very special guest. He's been a very special guest. He's been a very special guest. He's been a very special guest. He's been a very special guest. He's been a very special guest. He's been a very special guest. He's been a very special guest. He's been a very special guest. He's been a very special guest. He's been a very special guest. He's been a very long chat. I know. Well, you know, Bob is probably best known for playing lawyer Saul Goodman on Breaking Bad
他是一位非常特殊的嘉宾。他是一位非常特殊的嘉宾。他是一位非常特殊的嘉宾。他是一位非常特殊的嘉宾。他是一位非常特殊的嘉宾。他是一位非常特殊的嘉宾。他是一位非常特殊的嘉宾。他是一位非常特殊的嘉宾。他是一位非常特殊的嘉宾。他是一位非常特殊的嘉宾。他是一位非常特殊的嘉宾。进行了一场非常长的聊天。我知道。嗯，你知道，鲍勃最著名的角色可能是在《绝命毒师》中饰演律师索尔·古德曼
and Better Call Saul. And in the world of The Office, he plays Mark Franks, the manager of a Philadelphia real estate company that Pam has an interview with during season nine, Moving On. We just broke down, Moving On, part one and part two. So we're very excited to talk to Bob about his guest star on the show. Bob Odenkirk is a writer,
和《风骚律师》。而在《办公室》的世界里，他饰演马克·弗兰克斯，这是费城一家房地产公司的经理，潘在第九季《继续前进》中去该公司面试。我们刚刚剖析了《继续前进》上下集。所以我们非常高兴能和鲍勃谈谈他在剧中的客串。鲍勃·奥登科克是一位编剧，
he is a director, he is an actor. His career, it is extensive, very impressive. At the end of our interview, and Bob said something that I loved it. He said, I love talking about showbiz. He does. He's a real true fan of the medium, of television, of film, of sketch comedy, and it really comes through.
他是一位导演，他是一位演员。他的职业生涯非常广泛，令人印象深刻。在采访结束时，鲍勃说了一句我很喜欢的话。他说，我喜欢谈论演艺圈。他确实如此。他是这个媒介的真正的粉丝，无论是电视、电影还是小品喜剧，这一点真的很明显。
Well, I think it really comes through in this interview. He definitely talks about his time in the office, but mostly we talk about his career. We talk about writing on Saturday Night Live, working with Second City, Mr. Show, the Ben Stiller Show, and then also his transition from comedy into drama. One of the things that we talked about that I was trying so hard not to geek out on,
嗯，我觉得在这场采访中这一点真的很明显。他当然谈到了他在《办公室》的时光，但我们主要谈论的是他的职业生涯。我们谈到了在《周六夜现场》的写作，与第二城剧团合作，《鲍勃与大卫的情景喜剧》，《本·斯蒂勒秀》，以及他从喜剧向戏剧的转型。我们谈论的事情之一是，我极力克制自己不要表现得太狂热，
but he wrote the Saturday Night Live sketch, the motivational speaker for Chris Farley. Yes. I mean, that is like an epic sketch. It's the man that lives in the van down by the river. Gosh. If you haven't seen it, maybe before this interview, take a moment and go watch that sketch.
但他为克里斯·法利写了《周六夜现场》的小品《励志演说家》。是的。我的意思是，那简直是一个史诗级的小品。那个住在河畔货车里的人。天哪。如果你还没看过，也许在这次采访之前，花点时间去看一下那个小品。
It's so great. Bob tells us the background story of how that sketch came to be. I'm going to link to it all in our stories. And we'll also put a link in our show notes. So if you want to pause for a second and watch it, it's right down there in the show notes. You know, I've known Bob a very long time. His wife Naomi is my manager. She's my only manager that I've ever had.
它太棒了。鲍勃给我们讲述了那个小品诞生的背景故事。我会在我们的动态里提供链接。我们还会在节目笔记中放一个链接。所以如果你想暂停一会儿去看一下，它就在下方的节目笔记里。你知道，我认识鲍勃很长时间了。他的妻子娜奥米是我的经纪人。她是我至今为止唯一的经纪人。
So I have socialized with Bob and Naomi. We've gone to dinner. But I've never asked him about his career. Not at dinner. That'd be weird. No, no. But this was really fun for me because I got to hear the stories I've always wanted to hear, but I was too shy to ask basically. Right.
所以我跟鲍勃和娜奥米有过社交往来。我们一起吃过晚餐。但我从没问过他的职业生涯。不在晚餐时问。那会很奇怪。不，不。但这对我来说真的很有趣，因为我听到了我一直想听的故事，但基本上又太害羞而不敢问。对。
I started watching Bob on Mr. Show ages ago. And as someone that loves improv and sketch comedy, he's a legend. Yeah. Jenna, you know this, I was trying very hard not to be a total dork in front of him. I don't think I succeeded. But it was just so amazing to get to hear
我很早就开始看鲍勃的《鲍勃与大卫的情景喜剧》了。作为极其热爱即兴表演和喜剧小品的人，他是个传奇。是的。珍娜，你知道的，我在他面前极力克制自己不要表现得像个书呆子。我觉得我没有成功。但能听到
all of the stories of his early days in show business and the lessons he's learned along the way. Well, why don't we take a break? And then when we come back, our interview with Bob Odenkirk. Yeah. business and the lessons he's learned along the way. Well, why don't we take a break? And then when we come back, our interview with Bob Odenkirk. Yeah! Bob Odenkirk! Hi!
他早期在演艺圈的所有故事以及他一路上学到的教训，真的是太棒了。嗯，我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来，采访鲍勃·奥登科克。耶！商务以及他一路上学到的教训。嗯，我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来，采访鲍勃·奥登科克。耶！鲍勃·奥登科克！嗨！
Welcome to Office Ladies! Thank you, it's good to be here. Great always to see you and you. We're older friends. Yes, you guys. You've known each other a long time. A very long time. Yeah.
欢迎来到办公室女士！谢谢，很高兴来到这里。很高兴能见到你和你。我们是老朋友了。是的，你们。你们认识很久了。非常久。是的。
Bob, this was our first time acting together, was on The Office. Oh, yeah. But you had directed me in two projects, Melvin Goes to Dinner and Brother Solomon. I love it. Thank you for being a part of those. Oh my gosh. That Brother Solomon script is, to this day, one of the best scripts I've ever read. It was written by Will Forte. Yeah.
鲍勃，这是我们第一次一起演戏，就在《办公室》。哦，是的。但你曾导演过我的两个项目，《梅尔文去吃晚餐》和《所罗门兄弟》。我很喜欢。谢谢你们能参与其中。天哪。直到今天，《所罗门兄弟》的剧本仍然是我读过的最好的剧本之一。那是威尔·福特写的。是的。
It's Will Forte, Will Arnett, Kristen Wiig. Yeah. Malin Ackerman. Yes. So good. Yeah. Sean McBride, please. It's a great script. I wish I'd made a better film out of it. What are you talking about? Are you crazy? It's so funny. I have an idea that I wished that I had done.
那是威尔·福特、威尔·阿奈特、克里斯汀·韦伊。是的。玛琳·阿克曼。是的。太棒了。谢谢肖恩·麦克布莱德。这是一个很棒的剧本。我希望当时能把它拍成一部更好的电影。你在说什么？你疯了吗？它太搞笑了。我有一个我希望当时能拍出来的想法。
What? This is a big regret. What? We were not expecting to talk about this today. Let's kick it off with regrets. Okay. So it was such a funny script. Yes. Matt Berenson was one of the producers
什么？这是一个巨大的遗憾。什么？我们今天没料到会聊到这个。让我们从遗憾开始吧。好吧。这是一个非常搞笑的剧本。是的。马特·别伦森是制片人之一
and he had given it to me. And I wasn't quite sure what to do with it, but I loved Will Forte and I love Will Arnett. And I could picture it as being a really fun and sweet movie, which I needed. Sometimes you need that in your life. A lot of things that you make, and especially me, kind of have a harshness or an edge to them, you know? That's just common. I think in things, we like to watch things that are harsh because they hopefully aren't
他把它交给了我。我不太确定该怎么做，但我喜欢威尔·福特，我也喜欢威尔·阿奈特。我能把它想象成一部非常有趣且温馨的电影，而我当时正需要这个。有时你的生活中确实需要这个。你制作的很多东西，尤其是我的作品，往往带有一种严厉或尖锐感，你知道吗？这很常见。我认为在事物中，我们喜欢看那些严厉的东西，因为希望它们不
like your real life and you get to voyeuristically. Also, we like to see people under pressure. Yes. And pressured situations are often presented in movies and TV, right? Because you want to watch how people behave, you know, and you don't want to experience it yourself. You want to watch someone else. I find those movies relax me. Jenna. Oh, yeah.
像你的现实生活，你可以通过偷窥的方式去体验。此外，我们喜欢看人们处于压力之下。是的。而有压力的情境经常出现在电影和电视中，对吧？因为你想看人们如何表现，你知道，你不想自己去体验。你想看别人。我觉得那些电影能让我放松。珍娜。哦，是的。
Yes. Uncut gems. My horror films. Oh, I love Uncut Gems. Right, uncut gems is great for me. Oh, I love uncut gems. Right? Some people can't watch that. It's too much. But there's a lot of things I can't watch. Prince and the Popper I can't watch. I don't know that.
是的。原钻。我的恐怖片。哦，我爱《原钻》。对，《原钻》对我很合适。哦，我爱《原钻》。对吧？有些人看不下去。信息量太大了。但有很多东西我也看不了。马克·吐温的旧故事《王子与贫儿》，40年代或50年代拍成电影的那部，我看不下去。我不知道那个。
It's an old Mark Twain story made into a film in like the 40s or 50s. But anything where the thing could be solved if somebody would just be honest in a simple way drives me f***ing crazy. Yes! I'm like, just tell her! Just say, I'm the prince!
这是一个古老的马克·吐温故事，在40年代或50年代左右被拍成电影。但任何只要某个人能够以简单的方式保持诚实就能解决的问题，都会把我逼疯。是的！我就像，直接告诉她！就说，我是王子！
Yes, I changed clothes! It's obvious! Well, do you know, if the problem can be solved by simply being honest, you know, it really is, it really is, it drives me nuts. Some part of me inside is dying every second. That is so you, Jenna. It's so me, but uncut gems cannot be solved.
是的，我换了衣服！这很明显！好吧，你知道吗，如果这个问题只要简单地保持诚实就能解决，你知道，真的，真的，这让我抓狂。我内心的某一部分每时每刻都在死去。那真有你的风格，珍娜。这确实是我的风格，但《原钻》里的问题是无法解决的。
No, it cannot. No, and that guy's an addict and he's going off the rails and we're gonna watch him go off the rails. It is so great, I love it. She also, I don't know. Well, she thinks every day the like zombie apocalypse might happen. So that's how she operates. She's got, you've got your bag ready. You're like good to go survivalist. Bag, Angela, three bags. Okay, three bags. And so she likes, I think movies that are really stressful because then she's like,
不，无法解决。不，那个家伙是个瘾君子，他要崩溃了，而我们要看着他崩溃。这太棒了，我喜欢。她还，我不知道。嗯，她每天都觉得僵尸末日可能会发生。所以她就是这样运作的。她带着，你把包准备好了。你就像个随时准备好的生存主义者。包，安吉拉，三个包。好吧，三个包。所以她喜欢，我觉得那些压力很大的电影，因为这样她就会觉得，
I got this. Do you watch horror films? Yes, I'm a huge horror film lover. I hate them. I can't like a horror film. I can't watch them. No, really? No, I don't want to you have two choices You can let yourself be sucked into the invented reality and get scared Yeah, which most people do me or you can sort of mentally make an effort to remove yourself and say, I am in a theater right now, this is not real. And then you're not getting the experience, why are you there if all you're going to do is remove yourself from it? Because you don't want to get all scared. And so I don't see the value of either of those. I don't want to be scared So I don't see the value of either of those. I don't want to be scared and I don't want to sit somewhere and go, this isn't real,
这我能应付。你看恐怖片吗？是的，我是恐怖片的超级爱好者。我讨厌它们。我受不了恐怖片。我看不下去。真的吗？不，我不想，你有两种选择：你可以让自己沉浸在虚构的现实中并感到害怕，是的，大多数人都是这样，我或者你可以从精神上做出努力将自己抽离出来，然后说，我现在在电影院里，这不是真的。然后你就没有获得那种体验，如果你只是要将自己从其中抽离出来，那你为什么还要去呢？因为你不想感到害怕。所以我不觉得这两者有什么价值。我不想感到害怕，所以我看不出这两者有什么价值。我不想感到害怕，也不想坐在某处说，这不是真的，
this isn't real, this isn't real. It's a very practical way. What is, there's no in between. So I don't get it. I don't get it. I am in a strange way a very earnest person for a person in comedy, you know? I am oddly earnest. And I think it's one of the things that makes me a little, it's one of the reasons I think Steve Carell is a better,
这不是真的，这不是真的。这是一种非常务实的方式。有什么，没有中间立场。所以我不理解。我不理解。对于一个喜剧演员来说，我以一种奇怪的方式是一个非常真诚的人，你知道吗？我出奇地真诚。我觉得这也是让我有点，我认为这也是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔能表现得更好，
you know, is the one who got the role. It was me and Steve. I know. Yeah. That's right. But I really think when it comes to this, and there were other parts that I think I was up for, that Steve got. And it's because he's better at being genuinely fun.
你知道的，是那个获得这个角色的人的原因之一。当时是我和史蒂夫。我懂。是的。没错。但我真的认为说到这个，还有其他一些我认为我曾争取过但史蒂夫得到的角色。这是因为他更擅长表现出真正的有趣。
Uh-huh. Genuinely fun. And I think I bring with me a little bit too much earnest seriousness. And it's just kind of there. And there's nothing I can do about it, except play other roles where it's helpful to have that. And, you know, you just don't believe me as a purely light character.
嗯哼。真正的有趣。而我觉得我自身带有的真诚严肃感稍微多了一点。它就那么自然地存在着。对此我无可奈何，除了去扮演其他能够利用这种特质的角色。而且，你知道，你不会相信我是一个纯粹轻松的角色。
You don't. You just are looking for the darkness. And that's actually great in drama. Yeah. And that's a plus, you know, but in comedy, it's not a plus. I remember being on stage, I've told this story before, and it's a very minor story. But I really think that at the core of it is this thing I'm talking about, which is I was on stage with Jill Talley and Chris Farley at Second City. And we were improvising and I look at the audience, they're right here and they're laughing. And I'm thinking, if I was sitting there,
你不会。你只是在寻找黑暗面。这在戏剧中其实很棒。是的。这也是一个加分项，你知道的，但在喜剧中，这就不是加分项了。我记得在舞台上，我以前讲过这个故事，这是一个非常小的故事。但我真的认为它的核心就是我在谈论的这件事，那就是我和吉尔·泰利还有克里斯·法利一起在第二城剧团同台演出。我们在进行即兴表演，我看着观众，他们就在这里，而且在笑。我在想，如果我是坐在那里的观众，
I would be watching Chris Farley or Jill Talley. And the last person I'd be watching is Bob Odenkirk. And this is all during a scene. But you know, when you do a show seven times a week at Second City, your brain can really, like you can obviously do your scripted stuff and be thinking about groceries and anything. Yeah. Yeah. And you can even improvise and have your brain go, what is tomorrow morning? I got to get up early tomorrow morning.
我会看着克里斯·法利或吉尔·泰利。而我最不会看的人就是鲍勃·奥登科克。这一切都发生在场景进行中。但你知道，当你在第二城剧团一周演出七场时，你的大脑真的可以，就像你可以明显地表演你的剧本内容，同时想着杂货和任何事情。是的。是的。甚至你还可以进行即兴表演，同时脑子里在想，明天早上是什么时候？我明天早上得早起。
And I thought, boy, but if this was a drama, I think maybe I'd hold my own up here. Because there's a quality of comedy performers of many of them. This is, there's no across the board, hard and fast rules and this kind of theorizing, but where you can like relax if you know who they are, like right away
然后我想，天哪，但如果这是一部戏剧，我想也许我能在这里撑住场面。因为许多喜剧演员身上有一种特质。这不是，没有放之四海皆准的硬性规定和这种理论化，但你可以放松，如果你知道他们是谁，就像立刻
off their face, their smile, their energy. And anything that's murky is like, makes it harder to enjoy the light humor that's happening. is like makes it harder to enjoy the light humor that's happening. And I think that's where I really struggle and I've done plenty of sketch comedy and stuff, but I think I've never been the outstanding performer until I was able to do drama.
从他们的脸上，他们的微笑，他们的能量中看出。任何模糊不清的东西都会让人更难享受正在发生的轻松幽默。就像让人更难享受正在发生的轻松幽默一样。我想这就是我真正挣扎的地方，虽然我做过很多喜剧小品之类的事情，但我认为在我能够演戏剧之前，我从未成为过那个出类拔萃的表演者。
Then I was able to really kind of be 100% there and helpful in comedy. You know, I'm not bringing that light energy. I mean, I always point to Will Ferrell as like, he is the epitome to me of like, I'm smiling when he walks. Yes. Yes. He's on screen, and mate, you gotta smile. He can be doing the craziest, dumbest thing, but- Or like just the most. Yeah, you're smiling. Yeah, that's right He's just walked into the shoe store and picked up a pair of shoes and yes Wondering if he's gonna buy them and you're like on the floor, right? Yeah. Why is that? It's just
那时我才能真正做到百分之百地融入其中，并在喜剧中发挥作用。你知道，我并不是带来那种轻松的能量。我的意思是，我总是把威尔·法瑞尔当作例子，就像，他对我来说就是那种化身——当他走出来时我就在笑了。是的。是的。他在屏幕上，伙计，你得笑。他可以做最疯狂、最愚蠢的事情，但是——或者就像最。是的，你在笑。是的，没错。他只是走进了鞋店，拿起了一双鞋，然后是的，
Except is it a little because am I not effing it right now? Am I not pointing to it right now? It is a mirthful aura. Yeah. Well, Bob, you mentioned that you auditioned for Michael Scott, right? Yes, I did. And I know I've told this story before on the podcast, but Bob, you and I prepared for our test audition together
琢磨着他是不是要买它们，然后你就在笑倒在地了，对吧？是的。为什么会这样？只是
because your wife, Naomi Odenkirk, is my manager. And when I was asked to test for the role of Pam, she said, oh, Bob is testing for the role of Michael Scott. You two should get together. And I didn't have a lot of improv experience, so it was just so great to get to prepare with you in that way. And I remember that test. And it really came down to you and Steve Carell.
除了，是不是有一点因为我现在是不是没有演好？我现在是不是没有指出这一点？那是一种欢快的氛围。是的。好吧，鲍勃，你提到你曾为迈克尔·斯科特试镜，对吧？是的，我试过。我知道我以前在播客上讲过这个故事，但是鲍勃，你和我一起准备了试播试镜，
You know, I mean, I think the office was exactly what it needed to be. What you guys did and Steve did was exactly what it needed to be and it was great. So it's interesting. I mean, I, you know, I think I, I've been in the business even at that point. I've been in the business even at that point. I've been in it so long. I don't, I didn't audition for much in my career. When I was younger, I did auditions because they called me and said, you've got an audition. And I said, oh, I guess I go do it.
因为你的妻子娜奥米·奥登科克是我的经纪人。当我被邀请为潘这个角色进行试镜时，她说，哦，鲍勃正在为迈克尔·斯科特的角色试镜。你们两个应该聚一聚。我没有太多的即兴表演经验，所以能以那种方式和你一起准备真的是太棒了。我记得那次试镜。结果真的落在了你和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔之间。
But there came a point where I probably wasn't getting them even though I was getting roles, and I just never asked for them. I never called my agent and said, where are my auditions? I was just writing. I just woke up and wrote. I was thankful to audition. I had a great time auditioning, and I love Greg Daniels.
你知道，我的意思是，我认为《办公室》就是它本该成为的样子。你们和史蒂夫所做的事正是它所需要的，而且棒极了。所以这很有趣。我的意思是，我，你知道，我觉得我，甚至在那个时候我都已经在这一行了。甚至在那个时候我都已经在这一行了。我干这行太久了。我不，我的职业生涯中没有参加过多少试镜。我年轻的时候参加过试镜，因为他们打电话给我说，你有一个试镜。我说，哦，我想我得去。
We knew each other for a long time, and I love The Daniels. I mean, we knew each other for a long time and I love the office, the BBC version I love very much. So I, oh, a big part of it for me was curb. And of course in curb, you're improvising off, um, you know, an outline less than you guys had a great deal less, I would say, but you guys still had room to improvise, right? So I knew, oh, there's gonna be, this is like Curb, and I had had such a good time on Curb.
但后来到了某个阶段，尽管我一直在接角色，但我可能再也没有接到过试镜通知，而且我也从不主动索取。我从来没有给我的经纪人打电话问，我的试镜在哪里？我只是在写作。我醒来就写作。我很感激能去试镜。我试镜时度过了一段美好的时光，我爱格雷格·丹尼尔斯。
It was, doing that show, I was like, oh my God, this is the best thing you can get in show business. If you can get this to happen, a show with an ensemble of people that you like and that are funny and that you get room to just invent and just goof around. This is the best.
我们认识很长时间了，我爱丹尼尔斯一家。我的意思是，我们认识很久了，我非常喜欢《办公室》，非常喜欢英国版的《办公室》。所以，哦，对我来说很大一部分原因是《抑制热情》。当然，在《抑制热情》中，你是根据，嗯，你知道，一个大纲进行即兴表演的，比你们的要少得多，我会这么说，但你们仍然有发挥即兴的空间，对吧？所以我知道，哦，会有，这就像《抑制热情》，我在《抑制热情》里度过了一段非常美好的时光。
So I was excited to do the auditions for The Office because I knew it had that dimension. And look, when I did the Ben Stiller show, I walked away from that going, I gotta create a show again with my friends. Because waking up in the morning and picking up Andy Dick and picking up Jenny Garofalo and driving out to wherever the hell we had some cheap ass set
那是，拍那部剧时，我想，哦，天哪，这是你在演艺圈能得到的最好的东西。如果你能让这种事发生，一个由你喜欢的、搞笑的、并且有空间去创造和胡闹的人组成的演员阵容的节目。这是最棒的。
or were stealing locations and goofing around all day long and laughing is the greatest, you know? So when that show ended, I was like, I have to recreate that. And so when I finished Curb, I was like, I have to recreate that, but I still haven't. Are you still working on it? Not really.
所以我很高兴能为《办公室》进行试镜，因为我知道它有那个维度。看，当我制作《本·斯蒂勒秀》时，我离开时心想，我必须和我的朋友们再次创作一个节目。因为早上醒来去接安迪·迪克，接珍妮·加罗法洛，然后开车去见鬼知道哪里某个破烂不堪的片场，
This weird thing happened where I got into a drama and it's a lot of work and you don't improvise at all. And then I got into action movies, which again, you don't, you know, it's, you can, you know, obviously like any movie, but even maybe more, maybe it's more malleable than a lot of films, you know, you can work with the moments and invent. And that is especially true of the fight sequences, which is interesting. Yes. Wait, they're not just like, they are choreographed. They're absolutely choreographed and rehearsed. And that is especially true of the fight sequences. Really? Which is interesting. Yes.
或者去偷场地，一整天都在胡闹大笑，这是最棒的，你知道的？所以当那个节目结束时，我想，我必须重现那种感觉。因此，当我完成《抑制热情》时，我想，我必须重现它，但我还没做到。你还在为此努力吗？不算吧。
Wait, they're not just like... They are choreographed. They're absolutely choreographed and rehearsed. But when you get on set and it's time to do it, and you see a shot you didn't have, you see a move that you didn't think of, the set isn't quite built the way the layout was, and something goes wrong or looks better. And you go, no, no, no, no, no, don't hit me. I'll hit him.
发生了件奇怪的事，我开始演正剧了，那有大量的工作，而且完全没有即兴发挥。然后我开始拍动作片，同样地，你不会，你知道，你可以，你知道，显然就像任何电影一样，甚至可能更多，也许它比许多电影更具可塑性，你知道，你可以配合当下进行调整和发挥创作。打斗戏尤其如此，这很有趣。是的。等等，它们不只是……它们是编排好的。它们绝对是经过编排和排练的。打斗戏尤其如此。真的吗？这很有趣。是的。
He, you fall over and I'll punch you in the face. And then everybody goes, ah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And then you do that thing and then you look at it on camera and you go, Oh, that was awesome. That looks so real. and you go, oh, that was awesome. That looks so real. I was very surprised to discover that aspect of doing that, of the inventiveness and teamwork that those sequences,
等等，它们不只是……它们是编排好的。它们绝对是经过编排和排练的。但当你到了片场准备开拍时，你看到了一个原本没有的镜头，你看到了一个你没想到的动作，片场布景的布局和想象的有点不一样，有什么地方出错了或者看起来更好了。然后你说，不，不，不，不，不，别打我。我来打他。
I think, always take, but I mean, every movie's different, but I'm gonna keep those in my repertoire, I hope, if I make more action movies, which it looks like I might. But- Well, shocker, we have never done an action movie, Jenna and I. Does that surprise you? Does that surprise you? That we are not.
他，你倒下，我一拳打你脸。然后每个人都说，啊，对，对，对，对。接着你们做了那个动作，然后在镜头前回看，你会说，哦，太棒了。看起来太真实了。然后你会说，哦，太棒了。看起来太真实了。我很惊讶地发现拍戏的这一面，那种即兴创作和团队合作，
Well, doesn't it surprise you that I did? I mean, in a way, I remember when Naomi told me that you were going to do your first action film, and I was like, really? Really? Jenna, we shouldn't count ourselves out. Maybe we should out there for us. Absolutely. Mom Detectives. Action. Maybe we should out there for us. Absolutely.
我想，总是需要的，不过，每部电影都不同，但我希望把这些保留在我的作品库里，如果我拍更多动作电影的话，目前看来我可能会。好吧，说实话，我和珍娜从没拍过动作片。这让你感到意外吗？这让你感到意外吗？我们没有拍过。
Mom detectives. Action. That's our spinoff show. Detectives. Yeah, mom detectives. Detectives don't punch anything. We do. Mom detectives do.
好吧，我拍过这难道不让你意外吗？我的意思是，在某种程度上，我记得当娜奥米告诉我你要拍你的第一部动作片时，我是说，真的吗？真的吗？珍娜，我们不应该自我否定。也许有适合我们的机会。绝对的。妈妈侦探。动作片。也许有适合我们的机会。绝对的。
Solving crimes no one cares about. That's our log line. I did an improv pilot right before I got the office. Oh, wow. It was called Salon Royale. It was me and Ian Roberts and Betty Cahill and Dave Rizowski. Wow.
妈妈侦探。动作片。那是我们的衍生剧。侦探。对，妈妈侦探。侦探才不会随便出拳呢。我们会。妈妈侦探会。
And it was for the Oxygen Network. It was the most fun I had had like ever on a job. And I just knew it was gonna go. It just, it was just amazing. And then it didn't go, but if it had gone, I wouldn't have gotten the office. And I always think about that. But that kind of chemistry of having this loose outline and getting to improvise the
专门解决没人关心的案件。这就是我们的宣传语。我在拿到《办公室》之前做过一个即兴喜剧试播集。哦，哇。它叫《皇家沙龙》。我和伊恩·罗伯茨、贝蒂·卡希尔还有戴夫·里佐斯基一起演的。哇。
beats of a scene with people who you trust, and it's so much fun. Oh, it's the best. Yeah. I mean, I think acting in a drama that's really well written and intense and layered and all that, Better Call Saul, the star of the show is the writing, you know? And that has a great reward when you finish a scene and it's difficult and you feel that you connected
那是为氧气电视网制作的。那是我在工作中度过的最开心的一段时光。我当时就知道这剧肯定能播。它就是，太棒了。然后它没能开播，但如果它开播了，我就不会得到《办公室》的角色了。我总是会想到这一点。但那种拥有宽松大纲并开始即兴发挥的化学反应，
with it, honestly, but it's not as much fun as doing this, what we're talking about. And look, I would love, Jenna, I would love to find a show where I got to do this. It really is the most fun because I am a writer too. So it lets you use that part of you or you're inventing things and there's no question, you do this thing and they say cut and you all laugh.
和那些你信任的人一起表演场景的节奏，真的是太有趣了。哦，那是最好的。是的。我的意思是，我认为参演一部编剧精良、紧张且富有层次的正剧，比如《风骚律师》，剧中的明星其实是剧本，你知道吗？当你完成一个艰难的场景并且觉得你与之产生了真诚的共鸣时，那是很有成就感的，但它没有我们现在谈论的这种表演那么好玩。
And that's just a good sign. If you're laughing at work. We laughed every day. We did on the set of The Office. Like every day there was a moment where you ruined a take because you were laughing. Bob, you mentioned that you are also a writer and we wanted to read you this fan question from John Grant in Raleigh, North Carolina because he's going to be really happy today. John said, I am the world's biggest Bob Odenkirk fan. I became a huge fan of The Ben Stiller Show,
而且看，珍娜，我很乐意找到一个能让我这么演的节目。这真的是最有趣的，因为我也是个编剧。所以这能让你运用你身上那种在不断创造新事物的特质，毫无疑问，当你演完这一段，他们喊“咔”的时候，大家都笑了。
through to Mr. Show. Bumping into him on our honeymoon was unbelievable. So you have met John Grant from Raleigh, North Carolina. He went on to say, while he's often known for Saul Goodman, he is a comedy legend, responsible for Chris Farley's Matt Foley Van Down by the River sketch and Mr. Show was groundbreaking and legendary in comedy. Can you please have him on the podcast? Yes, John, we are having him on the podcast right now. Hi, John. How are you?
那绝对是个好兆头。如果你在工作时笑了。我们每天都在笑。我们在《办公室》片场就是这样。几乎每天都有某个时刻，你会因为笑场而毁掉一个镜头。鲍勃，你提到你也是个编剧，我们想把北卡罗来纳州罗利市的约翰·格兰特提出的这个粉丝问题读给你听，因为他今天会非常高兴。约翰说，我是全世界最大的鲍勃·奥登科克粉丝。我从《本·斯蒂勒秀》
I love that you were responsible for the Matt Foley Van Down by the River sketch. That's right. I am. I wrote that sketch. You wrote that for Chris. All by myself. That is bonkers. I will never forget writing that sketch.
一直到《鲍勃与大卫的情景喜剧》都是他的超级粉丝。在我们的蜜月旅行中偶遇他，简直难以置信。所以你已经见过来自北卡罗来纳州罗利市的约翰·格兰特了。他接着说，虽然他最著名的角色是索尔·古德曼，但他是一位喜剧传奇，创作了克里斯·法利关于“住在河畔货车里”的马特·福利小品，而且《鲍勃与大卫的情景喜剧》在喜剧界具有开创性和传奇色彩。你们能请他上播客吗？是的，约翰，我们现在正请他上播客呢。嗨，约翰。你好吗？
How did it come about? It was actually this weird, my whole time at SNL, and this is part of it because I wrote it at Second City. I was supposed to be at SNL, literally when I wrote it. I've told this story in my book. In my third season of SNL, my friend Tom Giannis got hired to direct the main stage at Second City.
我太喜欢你了，那个“住在河畔货车里的马特·福利”小品是你创作的。没错。是我。那个小品是我写的。我一个人写的。这太疯狂了。我永远不会忘记写那个小品的情景。
I grew up in Chicago and I went to Second City when I was 14 and it was a guiding light, you know? In that town of theater and comedy. And when I went to Chicago to do comedy, I very quickly sized it up and said, I am not waiting in that line. It's take classes and do the tour company and no, I'm not doing it. I'm gonna write my own stuff. I'm going to sink or swim, but nothing against Second City. It's great.
它是怎么构思出来的？其实这是一个奇怪的过程，我在《周六夜现场》的整个时期，部分原因是因为我在第二城剧团写了它。当我写它的时候，我本应该在《周六夜现场》工作的。我在书里讲过这个故事。在我在《周六夜现场》的第三季，我的朋友汤姆·贾尼斯被雇去导演第二城剧团的主舞台节目。
It's just, I don't want to, that's not why I'm in show business. You know, um, anyhow, I got invited to do, to do the main stage of Second City. I was my third year at Saturday Night Live. I had such a hard time at SNL. I was not very helpful there. I did help Robert Smigel with a lot of sketches. I wrote jokes and pitched things, and he used a lot of things that I gave him. But truthfully, I just struggled.
我在芝加哥长大，我14岁时就去过第二城剧团，那是那座戏剧和喜剧之城的指路明灯，你知道吗？当我来到芝加哥做喜剧时，我很快就评估了一下形势，并对自己说，我才不在那儿排队呢。上课、加入巡回演出公司，不，我不干。我要写我自己的东西。要么成，要么败，并不是对第二城剧团有意见。它很伟大。
And then my friend Tom calls me up and rehearsals begin in like February or March for their next review. And SNL in the last three months of its season has like two weeks on, two weeks off. Well, first of all, I grew up in Chicago. I got to say yes. If you invite me to pitch for the Cubs, I'm going to say, I'm going to suck, but I'm going to say yes. Yeah. Yeah. You know, and you invite me to do Second City, I'm going to suck, but I am going to take
只是我不想，那不是我进入演艺圈的原因。你知道，无论如何，我被邀请去第二城剧团的主舞台演出。那是我在《周六夜现场》的第三年。我在《周六夜现场》过得很艰难。我在那儿帮不上什么忙。我帮罗伯特·斯米格尔写了很多小品。我写笑话并提出点子，他用了我提供的很多东西。但说实话，我只是在苦苦挣扎。
you up on that. So I said yes. And then I would go to Chicago for my two-week breaks every month, plenty of time to write and rehearse and be with the cast and plan. But then on those weeks where we had shows, they still needed me to be coming in. We were developing a show. So I would work at SNL Monday night, Tuesday night,
然后我的朋友汤姆打电话给我，排练大约在二月或三月开始，为了他们的新剧目。而《周六夜现场》在其播出季的最后三个月里，大致是演两周，休两周。首先，我是在芝加哥长大的。我必须说“好”。如果你邀请我为小熊队出谋划策，我会说，我可能表现得很烂，但我会答应。是的。是的。你知道，如果你邀请我去第二城剧团，我可能会表现得很烂，但我会接受
all night, Wednesday read through in the afternoon, Wednesday after read through, fly to Chicago, do the improv set, and you know, then stay Thursday, stay Friday, fly back to New York on Saturday morning, and Lauren doesn't even know I left because Conan and Robert and everybody pretended I was still there just around the corner somewhere. But I wasn't particularly helpful, so I wasn't missed, you know? And it was really only for like three months, so I probably did that three times, right? Anyway, I did it.
你的邀请。所以我答应了。然后我每个月会去芝加哥两周休息，有充足的时间写作、排练、和演员呆在一起并做计划。但到了我们有演出的那些星期，他们仍然需要我过去。我们正在开发一个节目。所以我会在周一晚上、周二晚上
And it was extremely stressful. And I loved Chris, and Chris was great to me and loved me. And I loved Timmy Meadows, but there was tension in the world there, my little world there, because here I was, a guy who had left and was at that moment a writer on Saturday Night Live, coming back and bumping somebody who'd been standing in that line for eight years to get that part, to get that slot on the main stage show. I don't know why it didn't occur to me when I said I'll do it until I'd come to Chicago and done two weeks there.
通宵在《周六夜现场》工作，周三下午读剧本，周三读完剧本后，飞往芝加哥，演即兴喜剧，你知道，然后呆到周四、周五，周六早上飞回纽约，洛恩甚至不知道我离开了，因为柯南、罗伯特和其他所有人假装我还在某个拐角附近。但我并不是特别有用，所以大家也没有想念我，你知道吗？而且那其实只持续了三个月左右，所以我大概那样做了三次吧？不管怎样，我做了。
And why does everybody hate me? I mean, hate me, not everybody, but a lot of people. I mean, literally look me in the eye like, f*** you. I mean, people said s*** to me. They did. They said stuff. People did stuff. Physical stuff.
而且压力极大。我爱克里斯，克里斯对我很好，也很喜欢我。我也爱蒂米·梅多斯，但那里的世界存在着紧张气氛，我那个小小的世界里，因为在这里我是一个曾经离开、而在那一刻是《周六夜现场》编剧的人，回来却挤掉了一个在那个队伍里排了八年队才得到那个主舞台演出名额的人。我不知道为什么当我答应去做的时候，我脑子里没想到这一点，直到我来到芝加哥并在那里呆了两周。
What? Yes. Like what? They hazed you somehow? The lights would go out and I would get pushed. Oh my gosh! Comedy is no joke. Well, and I-
为什么每个人都讨厌我？我是说，讨厌我，不是每个人，但很多人。我是说，真的直视着我的眼睛，好像在说“去你妈的”。我是说，有人对我说过难听的话。他们确实说了。人们说了些话。人们做了一些事。体力上的事。
Don't jump the line in comedy. But I've got to say, I remember going home and going, well, I'd be pissed too at me. I don't need this job. Why did I say got to say, I remember going home and going, well, I'd be pissed too at me. I don't need this job. Why did I say yes to this? Just because I want to, because I grew up in Chicago. That's not right.
什么？是的。比如什么？他们对你进行某种欺凌？灯熄灭了，我被推了一下。天哪！喜剧可不是开玩笑的。嗯，我——
Those people who did say I'll wait in line should get this part. It was wrong of me to say I would do that. But I mean, what do you do? You get overwhelmed in the moment and you... Yeah. And again, you grew up in Chicago, Second City matters a lot.
在喜剧界可别插队。但我得说，我记得回到家后心想，好吧，如果我是他们，我也会生我自己的气。我根本不需要这份工作。我当时为什么说要接？只是因为我想，因为我在芝加哥长大。这不对。
That's right. And it mattered a lot to me. I love Second City. I just didn't want to wait in line, but I loved it. Anyhow, in the end, it worked out all right. I wrote a number of sketches for the main stage show that we did do, it did well, got good reviews. And one of those was Motivational Speaker.
那些说过愿意排队的人才应该得到这个角色。我答应去做这件事是错的。但我的意思是，你能怎么办？你在那一刻不知所措，然后你……是的。再说一次，你在芝加哥长大，第二城剧团对你意义重大。
And I wrote that after Chris improvised. We did an improv one night where we were playing faculty at a school doing an anti-drug whatever thing like, you know, and Chris did a coach, you know. He did his coach character, which is essentially Matt Foley. And also, I was listening, I think, to Tony Robbins at the time, in a sense. And so motivational speakers were kind of a new thing. And I thought, you know, what about this motivational speaker who uses himself as the negative example? Some stuck in me that that's funny that he's talking about himself, like, what a piece of s*** I was. You don't want to be like me.
没错。它对我很重要。我爱第二城剧团。我只是不想排队，但我爱它。不管怎样，最后结果还算不错。我为我们排演的主舞台节目写了不少小品，演出效果很好，评论也不错。其中一个就是《励志演说家》。
Live in a van down by the river. And so I was really lonely because I felt out of place at SNL, which mattered so much to me. I felt out of place at second city, which mattered so much to me. I knew I'd alienated some people who were good people who I shouldn't have done that. But, you know, I'm working off fumes, you know, and I love comedy. And I, I sat there in, and not many things come out the first time you write them the way they're done. And that sketch I wrote right out on a legal pad that night alone in my apartment. And it was essentially exactly what we all did.
那是克里斯进行即兴表演之后我写下来的。有一天晚上我们做了一个即兴表演，我们扮演学校里的教职员工，搞什么反毒品之类的活动，你知道的，克里斯演了一个教练，你知道。他演了他的教练角色，本质上就是马特·福利。而且，我想当时我也在某种意义上听了托尼·罗宾斯的录音。所以励志演说家在当时是一种新鲜事物。我在想，如果这个励志演说家把自己当作反面教材会怎么样？有个想法在我脑子里扎根了，那就是他谈论自己时很搞笑，比如，我以前是个多大的废物啊。你可千万别像我一样。
And because we then did it at Second City for the next few months, it didn't play on SNL for about a year and a half, two years. Wow. Chris really wanted to do it at SNL, but I think Lauren had a little bit of a, you did that in theater, we don't need that here. Which is totally, I get that. Eventually he relented and it did very well on SNL. But anyway, I'm very, you know, I feel very lucky that that all came to me in that moment and that it played so well. And my daughter once asked me when she was six, what's the most fun you ever had doing your job? And I without hesitation said every night at Second City Theater, the motivational speaker, I played the dad.
住在河畔的货车里。所以当时我感到非常孤独，因为我在《周六夜现场》感到格格不入，而那个节目对我来说意义重大。我在第二城剧团也感到格格不入，而那对我同样意义重大。我知道我疏远了一些好人，我不该那样做。但是，你知道的，我完全是在透支精力，你知道，我热爱喜剧。我，我坐在那里，而且很少有东西能在第一次写出来时就呈现出最终完成的那种状态。而那个小品是我那天晚上独自在公寓里在一本法律记录本上直接写下来的。它基本上就是我们后来演出的样子。
And the one, you know, besides for Chris just being so fun, every time he did it, he made it a point to make everyone laugh. He was not gonna leave the stage. By the way, every night, come on. And he, and he did it, he did it. And it was crazy, it was crazy. By the way, every night. Come on. And he did it. He did it. And it was crazy.
因为我们在接下来的几个月里一直在第二城剧团演它，所以它大概在一年半到两年后才在《周六夜现场》播出。哇。克里斯真的很想在《周六夜现场》演它，但我觉得洛恩有点那种“你已经在剧场演过了，我们这儿不需要”的心态。完全可以理解，我懂。最终他让步了，它在《周六夜现场》反响非常好。不管怎样，我非常，你知道，我感到非常幸运，那个灵感在那个时刻降临到我身上，而且反响这么好。我女儿在我六岁时曾问我，你工作时经历过最有趣的事是什么？我毫不犹豫地回答，在第二城剧团的每一个夜晚，演《励志演说家》的时候，我扮演爸爸。
It was crazy. It was the greatest vibe ever to be on stage doing that. And also the audience, look, he wasn't famous. He was just some guy in a show that they paid to see. But to watch that audience transform in four minutes from people who are like, who are these young actors? They're kind of funny as I could say, he's fun to,
还有一个，你知道的，除了克里斯本身就那么有趣之外，他每次演的时候，都一定会逗笑所有人。他绝不会轻易离开舞台。顺便说一句，每天晚上，拜托。而且他，他做到了，他真的做到了。太疯狂了，简直太疯狂了。顺便说一句，每天晚上。拜托。而且他做到了。他真的做到了。太疯狂了。
what's that guy's name? Chris Farley, I'm gonna love him forever. In four minutes was nuts. And you felt it, you felt it. And I've heard about that kind of magical stuff we've all heard about. This person came out and they sang one song and you kind of don't believe it, you know, because it doesn't happen that often. I mean, most things are hard earned, hard won and just incremental. But I'm telling you, at the end of that sketch, that was it.
简直疯狂。在舞台上表演那种节目的氛围简直是史上最棒的。还有观众，听着，他当时还不是个大明星。他只是演出里他们花钱买票来看的某个普通人。但是看着那些观众在短短四分钟内，从那种“这些年轻演员是谁？他们好像还挺搞笑的”的心态，变成“那家伙叫什么名字？克里斯·法利，我要永远爱他”，这在四分钟内发生简直太疯狂了。你能感受到，你真的能感受到。我听说过那种神奇的事情，我们大家都听说过。某个人走出来唱了一首歌，你都有点不敢相信，你知道的，因为这种事不常发生。我的意思是，大多数事情都是来之不易、苦心经营并且循序渐进的。但我告诉你，在那段小品结束时，就是那样。
350 more people were like, I love Chris Farley forever. It was cool. My favorite Mr. Show sketch, which we just showed our kids recently and they are now obsessed with, is the audition. Oh yeah. Well, I didn't write that at all. That was Dino Stamatopoulos. Oh my gosh.
又有350个人变成了：我永远爱克里斯·法利。太酷了。我最喜欢的《鲍勃与大卫的情景喜剧》小品，我们最近刚给孩子们看了，他们现在着迷了，那就是“面试”。哦，是的。嗯，那根本不是我写的。那是迪诺·斯塔马托普洛斯写的。哦，天哪。
Great. That is so funny. Itopoulos. Oh my gosh. Great. That is so funny. It's just great. It's too much. And also the hiker who went to Mount Everest but can't finish his story because he keeps falling into the thimbles. Oh yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes. I did write that. You did?
太棒了。太搞笑了。斯塔马托普洛斯。哦，天哪。太棒了。太搞笑了。简直太棒了。太夸张了。还有那个去爬珠穆朗玛峰却讲不完故事的登山者，因为他一直在掉进顶针里。哦，对，对，对，对，对，对。那个确实是我写的。真的吗？
Yeah. Okay, that was the other one we showed our kids. Yeah, it's called The Story of Everest. Yes, and he can't ever finish it. It was based on, Jay told us that we were sitting in the writer's room and he talked about how when he grew up, he had a grill, you know, one of those Weber grills. Sure. And it was in Chicago and they kept it inside the kitchen.
对。好吧，那是我们给孩子们看的另一个。对，它叫《珠穆朗玛峰的故事》。是的，而且他永远讲不完。这是根据，杰伊告诉我们的，当时我们正坐在编剧室里，他谈到他小时候家里有个烤炉，你知道的，那种韦伯牌烤炉。当然。它在芝加哥，他们把它放在厨房里面。
It was filled with holes. That seems like a really dangerous idea. It was during the winter or something. Cold, okay, yeah. But they didn't grill on it. No, you have to put it outside to light it on fire. Okay, I want to make sure. Let's just say you really should, recommend it.
里面全是洞。听起来这主意太危险了。那是冬天还是什么时候。天冷，好吧， yeah。但他们不在上面烧烤。不，你得把它搬到外面去点火。好吧，我想确认一下。只能说你真的应该，强烈建议。
And one time his uncle leaned on it and it fell over because ash went everywhere. They cleaned everything in the kitchen. Somebody came in and said, what are you guys doing in here? And the uncle said, they had finished cleaning. Oh, well, earlier I was telling a story and I leaned on the grill right here and he did it again. And that killed me. That killed me.
有一次他叔叔靠在上面，烤炉倒了，因为烟灰到处都是。他们把厨房里的一切都打扫干净了。有人走进来问，你们俩在里面干嘛呢？叔叔说，他们已经打扫完了。哦，对了，刚才我正讲着故事，我靠在这个烤炉上，然后他又做了一次。这把我笑死了。这把我笑死了。
I said, that's the greatest thing I've ever heard. That's so dumb. And so it became thimbles. And a fun thing about that sketch is I love that sketch. But there are people who for them is like me with horror films. Like, they don't like that dumb repetition thing that can be so funny in comedy. But you know, we structured it. It's very structured.
我说，这是我听过最棒的事。太蠢了。所以后来就成了“顶针”。那个小品有趣的一点是，我很喜欢它。但有些人对它就像我对恐怖片的感觉一样。比如，他们不喜欢喜剧里那种可能非常搞笑的愚蠢重复。但你知道，我们构建了结构。它结构非常严密。
Yes. But also, let's do one more than the structure asks for. And just see if we get a bigger laugh. And we did it and it got nothing. The audience, everything you hear on Mr. Show is live laughter, right? We didn't sweeten laughs. But we did take out that beat
是的。但是，让我们比结构要求的再多重复一次。看看能不能引发更大的笑声。我们照做了，结果毫无反应。观众的反应，你在《鲍勃与大卫的情景喜剧》里听到的所有笑声都是现场真实的笑声，对吧？我们没有后期加笑声。但我们确实删掉了那个拍子，
because in the dress rehearsal of show, leaned on it one more time than is in the sketch with no buildup or anything, just to see if we would get another good laugh. People went dead and went oh because they went from thinking this is so crazy funny. I can't believe how many times are they going to do this to oh you f**k you. You are not going to make me sit through this. How many times, you know? You know, my dad's favorite joke when he was alive, it would make me laugh so hard. It's my dad anticipating something that's about to happen that he's already just
因为在节目的彩排中，（角色）比小品里多靠了一次，没有任何铺垫，就是为了看看能不能得到更大的笑声。结果全场鸦雀无声，大家发出“哦”的声音，因为他们的心情从“这太疯狂太好笑了，他们究竟要重复多少次”变成了“哦，去你妈的。你休想让我坐在这里硬挺过去。到底要重复多少次”，你知道吗？你知道，我爸爸生前最喜欢的笑话，总能把我笑得前俯后仰。那是我爸爸在预料即将发生的事情，而那件事他刚刚才
seen, like there was nothing funnier to him and you describing that just brought me right back. He would get so tickled that as a kid, I would just watch him, like, wait for that thing and he would be like, like, like, He was building up. Yes. And it was so fun. And I think I have a soft spot in my heart for those kinds of jokes now because I can
看过，对没有什么比这更让他觉得好笑了，而你刚才的描述直接把我带回了那个场景。他会觉得那么好笑，以至于我小时候就看着他，比如，等着那个时刻的到来，然后他会像这样，像这样……他在做铺垫。是的。真的太有趣了。我想我心里现在对那种笑话情有独钟，因为我能
hear my dad waiting for it to happen and just losing his mind. Yeah. I like that kind of humor too. I mean, we did a sketch called Hunger Strike that also pissed people off because of how repetitive it is in the joke. But man, I love that sketch. That's David Cross playing a guy on a hunger strike giving a speech, and all he can talk about is the food he's going to eat. And he's supposed to be talking about like his political, you know, standard bearing, but he's just going, I have one message for everyone.
听到我爸爸在等着它发生，然后笑到崩溃。是的。我也喜欢那种幽默。我的意思是，我们做过一个小品叫《绝食抗议》，由于笑话的重复性，它也把人惹毛了，但是天哪，我太喜欢那个小品了。那是大卫·克罗斯饰演一个绝食抗议的人在发表演讲，而他满脑子想的、能谈论的只有他要吃的食物。他本该谈论诸如他的政治立场之类的，但他却一直在说，我给大家传达一个消息：
Can I please have a hot dog? Or whatever, you know, you can't stop. Bob, we haven't even barely talked about the office. We should, we should probably. Yeah, I think people listening to this might like The Office, the TV show. This was so much fun. Oh, by the way, I couldn't wait to do it. When I was invited by Greg to come do a rendition of Michael Scott,
能给我来个热狗吗？或者诸如此类的话，根本停不下来。鲍勃，我们甚至都还没怎么聊《办公室》。我们应该聊聊，大概应该聊一下。是的，我想听这个的观众可能会喜欢《办公室》这部电视剧。这太有趣了。哦，顺便说一句，我迫不及待想来。当我被格雷格邀请去扮演迈克尔·斯科特的翻版时，
I was like, this is the best. How did you get approached? Did Greg just call you? They just called, yeah. And did he pitch you the idea? Because I remember the idea was, Pam's gonna go in for an interview at this real estate office. And did he pitch you the idea? Because I remember the idea was Pam's gonna go in for an interview at this real estate office.
我就觉得，太棒了。你是怎么被联系上的？是格雷格直接给你打电话吗？他们直接打电话来的，是的。他向你推销这个想法了吗？因为我记得当时的想法是，潘要去费城的那家房地产公司面试。他向你推销这个想法了吗？因为我记得当时的想法是潘要去费城的那家房地产公司面试。
And they thought it would be really funny if it was like her life was gonna repeat itself now in Philadelphia. And her boss is basically Michael Scott. And then when Greg told me that he was gonna call you and have you play Mark, I was like, oh my gosh, this is like, this is a dream come true.
他们觉得如果她的生活现在要在费城重演会非常搞笑。而她的老板基本上就是迈克尔·斯科特。然后当格雷格告诉我他要打电话给你让你演马克时，我就想，哦，天哪，这简直是，这简直是梦想成真。
And so you were just like, yes, I'm up for it. Oh yeah, like I said, I wanted to do a show, I'll do any, almost any show like this. Any show that where you have the improv as part of the part, as part of acting in it, is I think one of the great things. So, yes, absolutely. I also think, you know, the whole thing of like having stories told about it was you or Correll, you know, gives me a chance to do it and show people what I would have done,
所以你当时就毫不犹豫地答应了，是的，我愿意。哦，对，就像我说的，我想做一个节目，我愿意做任何，几乎任何像这样的节目。任何将即兴表演作为表演一部分的节目，我认为都是最棒的事情之一。所以，是的，绝对愿意。我也觉得，你知道，流传的关于是你还是卡瑞尔去试镜的故事，给了我一个机会去尝试，并向人们展示我会怎么做，
you know, although I do think that what I was doing was more a tribute to Steve because that's what I was supposed to be doing. You know, my character was meant to be very much a version of what Steve had invented when he played the character. Well, there was one thing that was all you, and we even got a fan question about it from Ella Edwards in England and Chloe M in Grand Prairie, Alberta, who said,
你知道，虽然我认为我当时的做法更多是对史蒂夫的一种致敬，因为那就是我应该做的。你知道，我的角色本来就被设计成很大程度上带有史蒂夫在饰演该角色时所创造的风格。好吧，有一件事完全是你自己的，我们甚至收到了来自英国的埃拉·爱德华兹和阿尔伯塔省大草原城的克洛伊·M的粉丝提问，她们说，
"'Jenna mentioned that her and Bob Odenkirk practiced their audition together and that Bob brought his guitar to do a song. Was your audition prep the inspiration for that scene in this episode?' It was. It was. I told Greg, I said, "'Greg, you have to tell Bob to bring his guitar,'
“珍娜提到她和鲍勃·奥登科克一起练习试镜，鲍勃还带了一把吉他去唱了一首歌。你们的试镜准备是那一集中那个场景的灵感来源吗？”确实是。是的。我告诉格雷格，我说：“格雷格，你必须告诉鲍勃带上他的吉他，”
because Bob, doing that moment with you was so funny. I should say, I had been auditioning for the office for months, and then Naomi was like, hey, they just called Bob and asked him to come test for the role. I was like, well, right, of course. Bob didn't do all the crap I did. She was like, do you guys want to just do something together? Because there's going to be improv.
因为鲍勃，和你一起演那场戏太搞笑了。我得说，我为了《办公室》试镜了好几个月，然后娜奥米就说，嘿，他们刚刚打电话给鲍勃，让他去为这个角色试镜。我就想，好吧，当然。鲍勃可没像我那样做一堆废话。她说，你们俩要不要一起练习一下？因为会有即兴表演部分。
You guys could just work on your improv part together. I sat down with you and you pulled out that guitar and you started singing a song that was very similar to the one in the episode. Because the thing that was similar was the part where you're like, you're singing about how I'm attractive, but like I'm taken, but that's okay, but that's not what this is about anyway. And it was so funny.
你们可以一起练习即兴表演的部分。我坐下来和你一起排练，你掏出那把吉他，开始唱起一首和剧中非常相似的歌。因为相似的地方在于，你在歌里唱到我很有吸引力，但是，比如我是个有主的人，但没关系，但这并不是重点之类的。那真的太搞笑了。
And so I was like, Greg, you have to make him do that in this episode. And so that was, you were just improving that song, if I remember. You're just reading the resume, right? Yeah, but I think I'm going to guess that Greg told me to and gave me the structure of it, probably. I think my memory is that he was like, just here's her resume. Yeah.
所以我当时就说，格雷格，你必须让他在这一集里这么演。所以那是，如果你还记得的话，你当时只是即兴创作了那首歌。你只是在念简历，对吧？对，但我想我猜是格雷格让我这么做的，并且可能给了我一个结构。我的记忆是，他当时就像，这里有她的简历。对。
Sing her resume to her. Yes. And clung on it. Listen guys, I don't remember all that much except that I had the greatest time and I got to go on and on and on. Yeah. Which I'm sure you guys didn't do on a regular basis, because you could never have shot the whole show.
把她的简历唱给她听。是的，然后就发挥开了。听着，伙计们，我不记得那么多了，除了我度过了一段最美好的时光，而且我可以说个没完没了。是的。我知道你们在常规拍摄时肯定不会这么做，因为那样你们永远也拍不完整部剧。
I mean, I remember I walked around the office. Yes. And I talked to every person. Yeah. Like, yeah, I mean, I was just burning digital space. It's all in the episode though. Like that was the thing. Yeah.
我的意思是，我记得我在办公室里到处走。是的。我和每个人都交谈了。是的。就像，我的意思是，我简直是在疯狂消耗数字存储空间。不过所有的内容都在那一集里了。就像那是关键。是的。
Nothing got cut out. Yeah. Was it a two parter or a one hour show or something? It was, I think, meant to be a one parter, but then they made it into two parts because they loved it all so much. Yes, it became a two parter. Look, what an honor. I'm so glad it worked out.
没有什么被剪掉。是的。那是上下集，还是一个小时的特别节目之类的？我想，它本来打算作为单集播出的，但后来他们把它分成了上下集，因为大家都太喜欢了。是的，它成了一个上下集。看，这是多么大的荣誉。我很高兴它成功了。
It's the best. The best. Well, it's funny, Bob, because I don't even know if I've ever told you this, but Angela and I were driving here this morning and she was like, well, I know Bob, but I don't know him super well. You've known him a long time. What's he like? And I'm like, Angela, I have known Bob so long.
太棒了。最棒的。好吧，这很有趣，鲍勃，因为我甚至不知道我有没有对你讲过这件事，但安吉拉和我今天早上开车来的时候，她说，嗯，我认识鲍勃，但我不是很熟。你认识他很久了。他是个什么样的人？我说，安吉拉，我认识鲍勃太久了。
I have been to dinner with him. I have worked with him. I am so nervous around him because he is a comedy legend. And I, it's like, I just, I'm like, Angie's the nicest guy, but I'm telling you, I get so nervous because it was like, now you're doing Breaking Bad and you're doing Better Call Saul and it's like, what can he not do? What doesn't he do? This is like, it's getting worse.
我和他一起吃过饭。我和他一起工作过。我在他面前还是觉得很紧张，因为他是喜剧传奇。而且我，感觉就像，我简直，我跟安吉拉说他人超级好，但我告诉你，我还是紧张得要命，因为感觉就像，现在你演了《绝命毒师》，又演了《风骚律师》，这就好像，还有什么是他不会的？有什么是他不做的？这简直，越来越离谱了。
There's an answer to that question. But I mean, it's just such an honor to have you here today. You know I can't sing. If you've watched my comedy, you know I can't sing. Well, I can't sing either. I can't either. And you know I love to make people listen to me sing badly.
这个问题有答案。但我的意思是，今天能请到你来到这里真的是无上的荣耀。你知道我不会唱歌。如果你看过我的喜剧，你就知道我不会唱歌。好吧，我也不会唱歌。我也不会。你知道我喜欢让人听我五音不全地唱歌。
I really do. But you know, there's really, there's two things that I can do. I can write sketches and I can do a certain kind of drama acting. And I really, and I believe I can do those things. You know, by the way, I am good with people owning what they're good at. We are in showbiz and we're constantly meeting people who are great at things and they're like,
我真的很喜欢。但你知道，其实有两件事我是可以做到的。我可以写小品，我能演某种特定类型的正剧。而且我真的，我相信我能做到这些。顺便说一句，我挺赞成人们承认自己擅长什么的。我们身处演艺圈，不断遇到那些在某些方面很厉害的人，他们却会说，
really, do you like my singing? Elvis Presley, you think I'm any good, really? You want Elvis Presley to go, yeah, I can sing. What the fuck? This is the one thing I can do. Yeah, I mean, you're not a dick. You're not, you know, you want, I'm not saying I'm anywhere near that level, but you know, if you can do something, just calm it.
真的吗？你觉得我唱得好？猫王，你觉得我唱得有哪怕一点好吗，真的？你难道想让猫王说：“对，我会唱歌。”操，这是我唯一会做的事。对，我的意思是，你又不是个混蛋。你不是，你知道，你想，我不是说我达到了那种水平，但你知道，如果你能做到某件事，就大大方方承认吧。
Own it. It's okay to know you can do it. Calm down. Yeah. You know, you're 60 years old now. There's hundreds of hours of you doing it. Don't pretend you can't believe that anyone has ever seen you do, because you see that all the time.
承认它。知道自己行，这没什么。冷静点。是的。你知道，你现在都60岁了。你有几百小时的表演记录。别假装你不相信有人见过你演戏，因为这种事你随时都能见到。
Yeah. Anyway, so I'll admit that I've written a lot of sketches and I'm good at that. And that I can do drama, which is a bit of a surprise to me. But I also do think it marries up with the kind of energy that I, that we all have what we have. You know, we also are used to seeing people who wish they were different, wish they had a different energy. You know, a drama person who wishes they could do comedy. And you know, you want to go, well, I don't know. No. Yeah.
是的。不管怎样，所以我承认我写过很多小品，而且我在这方面很擅长。我也能演正剧，这对我自己来说都有点意外。但我也觉得它与我们所有人身上那种固有的能量相契合。你知道，我们平时也看惯了那些希望自己与众不同、希望拥有不同能量的人。你知道，一个渴望演喜剧的正剧演员。然后你会想说，嗯，我不知道。不。是的。
Just calm down. It's okay. I mean, be thankful for what you have. For what you can do. I didn't finish my thought from the beginning, which is brother Solomon. Your greatest regret? Yeah. Oh yeah. Look, it is the greatest script and I love everybody involved. What if we had done that? What if I had engineered it such, not that I could have, I'm not sure I could have, where we shot it like an indie movie. Put them, don't build sets. Really work with the real world.
冷静点。没关系的。我的意思是，为你所拥有的感恩吧。为你所能做到的感恩。我没把一开始的话说完，也就是《所罗门兄弟》。你最大的遗憾？对，哦，对。看，那是最棒的剧本，我爱里面所有的每个人。如果我们当时把它拍出来会怎样？如果我把它运作得好一点，倒不是说我一定能做到，我不确定我能不能，把它拍成一部独立电影。让他们去演，别搭景。真正去贴近现实世界。
Put those two characters in the real world as much as possible. I think it might've worked. Like really work. Many people come up and say they enjoy that movie. It's so funny. It's so funny. It's interesting. This is like... They're just, I think it would be better. I think it would really work. Like it would really be like, I know why they made that movie. That has a purpose. And to take a very lighthearted,
尽量把这两个角色放到现实世界中去。我觉得可能真行得通。就像真的行得通。很多人走过来说他们很喜欢那部电影。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。很有趣。这就好比……他们只是，我觉得这样会更好。我觉得真的会行得通。就像真的会让人觉得，我知道他们为什么要拍那部电影。那是有目的的。而且要把一部非常轻松、
conceptual behavior comedy and sink it into a world that feels incredibly real because it is, would be a neat thing. I don't know. Well, do you find this with certain projects, and I think it might be especially true of directors because I've talked to other directors about this before, and Lee, my husband, when he directs something, he always has this happen, which is that when you finish the project, you're a better artist than you were when you started it.
概念化的喜剧融入一个让人感觉无比真实的世界里，因为它的确如此，那会是一件很棒的事。我不知道。好吧，你在某些项目中也会发现这种现象吗？我觉得导演尤其如此，因为我以前和其他导演讨论过这个问题。我的丈夫李，当他执导某部作品时，总是会遇到这种情况，那就是当你完成这个项目时，你会成为一个比刚开始时更优秀的艺术家。
And you can only, like, you are better than you were when you started that thing, because that thing helped you grow. And so if you did it again, it would be better probably because you're better. Like you had, but you did it again, it would be better probably, because you're better. Like you had, but you had to do it to learn the thing, right?
而且你只能，比如说，你比刚开始做那件事时更优秀了，因为那件事帮助你成长了。所以如果你再做一次，可能会更好，因为你更优秀了。就像你曾经，但如果你再做一次，可能会更好，因为你更优秀了。就像你曾经，但你必须先去做才能学会这件事，对吧？
I think with directing in particular, you can always look back. I mean, unless you're just like Steven Spielberg or something, I guess, and you just nail it on the landing the first time, right? I think you're probably right, yes. There's something there. Yeah.
我觉得特别是导演，你总是可以回过头来看。我是说，除非你就像史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格那样，我猜，第一次出手就能大获成功，对吧？我想你大概说得对，是的。这里面确实有些门道。对。
Like an artist's journey. Yeah, like you couldn't know what you didn't know. Right. You know, it's like, there's what you know, there's what you don't know, and then there's what you don't know that you don't know. Yes, I mean, I think- And you can't know that until you know it.
就像艺术家的心路历程。对，就像你无法预知你所不知道的事情。没错。你知道的，这就好比，有你知道的事，有你不知道的事，还有你不知道自己不知道的事。是的，我的意思是——而且在你真正了解之前，你是无法知道的。
This is like, the thing about showbiz, and there's luck involved, and there's so many elements involved and you know I think about older actors and how in a weird way they may have learned there's a lesson in this and what we're talking about too where I sometimes feel that they're extremely aware that they've done projects where they worked so hard and they worked so earnestly and everybody did their best and it didn't play well. It didn't work. And then they've done projects where people showed up a little bit half-assed, wasn't figured out, they were scared, and it was great. It really worked. And I think one thing people come away with after that is it's not worth trying. Just make the damn thing.
这就好比，关于演艺圈这回事，里面有运气的成分，有太多因素牵涉其中。你知道的，我会想到一些老演员，在某种奇怪的意义上，他们可能已经从中吸取了教训，这与我们刚才讨论的内容也有关，有时我感觉到他们极其清楚，他们曾经参与过一些项目，为此付出了巨大的努力，极其认真地工作，所有人都尽力了，但反响并不好。行不通。然后他们也参与过一些项目，大家都有点敷衍了事，剧本没琢磨透，大家都提心吊胆，结果却大获成功。效果真的很好。我想人们从中得出的一个结论就是，努力根本不值得。直接把这破玩意儿拍出来就完了。
It might work, it might not. Who the hell knows? It's not worth sweating it too much. It's not so precious. Yeah, young actors and writers are like every second of the day trying to manipulate every little corner of that project to make it great. And the truth lies somewhere in between these two.
管它行不行得通呢。谁特么知道啊？不值得为它过分焦虑。没那么金贵。对啊，年轻的演员和编剧每天每时每刻都在试图操控这个项目的每一个小角落，好让它变得伟大。而真相往往介于这两种极端之间。
The other thing is so many people wanna be directors. And I encourage everybody to do and make everything. Just do stuff. And that's what, make stuff today, every day. Write a sentence, write a poem, write a journal entry, do a drawing every day. I hate to put the kibosh on anyone's dreams at all. I encourage people, but when you meet somebody like Spielberg, who's just a director, you know, he's born for this. You do go like, oh, well, yeah,
还有一件事，有太多人想当导演了。我鼓励每个人去做任何事，拍任何东西。只管去做就行了。这就是，今天就搞点东西出来，每天都这样。写一句话，写一首诗，写一篇日记，每天画一幅画。我讨厌泼任何人冷水的梦想。我鼓励大家，但当你遇到像斯皮尔伯格这样的人，他天生就是个导演，你知道的，他就是为这而生的。你确实会忍不住感叹，哦，好吧，是的，
I could direct something, but he's a director. Yeah. I don't want to be a director or a writer. I hate both of those things. Yeah, I'm starting to think I hate writing a little bit. What? I don't know. I'm 61. Shouldn't you get more patient as you get older? I'm working on a couple movie scripts,
我或许能导演点什么，但他可是个导演。对啊。我不想当导演，也不想当编剧。这两样我都讨厌。对，我开始觉得我有点讨厌写作了。什么？我不知道。我都61岁了。随着年纪越来越大，人难道不应该更有耐心吗？我正在写几个电影剧本，
and I'm stalled out in a couple different ways. And it really is making me angry. Like what the f***? How? Come on. Really? Still? But yeah, yeah.
而且在好几个方面都卡壳了。这真的让我很恼火。搞什么鬼？怎么会这样？拜托。真的吗？到现在还这样？但是，好吧，好吧。
I mean, it's just the hardest f***. Some people love writing and I'm like, really? You love writing? You love looking at a completely blank page and having to put something on it? To me, that's just like the worst ever. That's my favorite part because I pace and I get ideas and I just throw it all down and I'm excited, but then my structure sucks, but that's what you're good at, lady. I love to edit.
我是说，这简直是世上最难的折磨。有些人就是热爱写作，而我想：真的吗？你居然热爱写作？你居然喜欢面对一张完全空白的纸，然后不得不往上面填东西？对我来说，这简直是有史以来最糟糕的事。那可是我最喜欢的环节，因为我会来回踱步，产生各种灵感，然后把它们全部倾倒出来，我感到很兴奋，不过我的结构往往一塌糊涂，但这就是你擅长的领域啦，大姐。我喜欢剪辑。
I'll edit till the cows come home. Give me something to chew on and I can make it great, but I am not putting any ink on a blank page. I don't have anything for that. We wrote a book together and this was like I think the way our personalities complemented each other But when I told you and I was like John I want us to write a book together I want it to be a New York Times bestseller and we're gonna do it and she was like Angela I need you to hear me. I am never writing another book again. I wrote it one book by myself Yeah, you wrote a great book. Yeah. Thank you.
叫我剪到天荒地老我都行。给我点干货，我能把它弄得很棒，但我绝不会在白纸上落下一个字。我对那个可真是一点办法都没有。我们曾一起合写过一本书，这大概就是我们性格互补的方式吧。但当时我告诉你，我说：“约翰，我想让我们一起合写一本书。我希望它能成为《纽约时报》畅销书，我们一定能做到。”然后你说：“安吉拉，我需要你听我说。我再也不想写另一本书了。”我自己写过一本书了。对，你写了一本很棒的书。对。谢谢你。
Yeah. Well, I should give Lee credit for a lot of that. Say the name of your book. What is it? I forgot. It's an actor's library. Oh, Actors Life. It's called The Actor's Life, a Survival Guide. It's really great.
是的。好吧，其中很大一部分功劳我得归功于李。说出你的书名。叫什么来着？我给忘了。是一本演员的图书馆。哦，演员的生活。书名叫《演员的生活：生存指南》。真的非常棒。
It is fantastic. And then we wrote another one together and so you did do it. So you are a writer and you're a good writer. I don't enjoy it. Yeah, I'm talking about. I don't enjoy it. I hate it so much. It's so much work. It's such a slog. By the way, I get I love the feeling of reward from having written and when it turns out and I know I'm proud of it I get that that, of course. Good for you, yes. But getting to that point,
简直太棒了。后来我们又一起合写了一本，所以你确实做到了。所以你是个作家，而且是个优秀的作家。我一点也不享受这个过程。对，我说就是这个。我一点也不享受。我太讨厌它了。有太多的工作要做。简直是一场煎熬。顺便说一句，我明白，我喜欢写作完成后的那种成就感，当它呈现出来而且我知道我为此感到骄傲时，我懂那种感觉，当然。那真为你高兴，是的。但要到达那个阶段，
I mean, don't tell me you do that every day when you write. Cause no way. No. But I do think there are people like Stephen King must be- He must like writing. Having the time of his life. He has a bowl of popcorn. He has like cold waters. Soda's ready to go. You know, sodas. He has a bowl of popcorn. He has like cold waters.
我是说，别告诉我你每天写作时都是这么过的。因为绝不可能。才没有呢。不过我确实觉得肯定有人像斯蒂芬·金那样——他肯定喜欢写作。正享受着他人生中最快乐的时光。他有一碗爆米花。准备好了冰水。汽水也随时待命。你知道的，汽水。他有一碗爆米花。准备好了冰水。
Soda's ready to go. You know, sodas. He's enjoying it. He's like eating and typing and laughing. Snacks. This is how we imagine Stephen King's writing day. He's giggling and laughing. He loves it. He's such a laugher. And going, oh, what? No way! And then typing more.
汽水也随时待命。你知道的，汽水。他乐在其中。他一边吃一边打字，还在哈哈大笑。零食。这就是我们想象中斯蒂芬·金的写作日常。他咯咯笑着，哈哈大笑。他太喜欢了。他真是个爱笑的人。还会一边说：“哦，什么？不会吧！”然后继续打字。
And going, oh, what? No way! And then typing more. You know, please tell me that's what he's done with his life. If he was dragging his ass through it like I do, then I want to say to him, please stop. Pivot, pivot. With the rest of the time you have left to breathe and see and do things, don't torture yourself anymore. The only part of that scenario that I do is the eating. You do. You do the popcorn?
还会一边说：“哦，什么？不会吧！”然后继续打字。你知道的，拜托告诉我他这一生就是这么过的。如果他也像我一样步履维艰地熬过去，那我真想对他说：求求你停下来吧。转换方向吧，转型吧。用你剩下的、还能呼吸、去看世界、去体验生活的宝贵时间，别再折磨自己了。那个场景里我唯一会做的事就是吃东西。你确实会。你真的会吃爆米花吗？
I do a ton, bowls and bowls of carbs. You made a whole box of, was it like Cheez-Its or something one time? No, Trader Joe's has these tiny- It's like a cracker. ...cheap sandwich crackers, mini cheese sandwich crackers, and I can eat them at the box full. Are they good, huh? They're terrific. I'll just sit there.
我吃超多，一碗又一碗的碳水化合物。你曾经做过满满一盒，是脆棋饼干（Cheez-Its）还是别的什么东西来着？不，Trader Joe's（乔氏超市）有一种迷你的——就像是一种饼干。……廉价的三明治饼干，迷你奶酪三明治饼干，我可以一盒一盒地吃个精光。好吃吗，哈？棒极了。我就会一直坐在那里。
Are they like the little round ones? Little round ones. Oh, I think we have some. My son bought them. They're great. My son wants them. Don't eat one. Don't eat one unless you want to eat a box of them.
是那种小圆饼干吗？小圆饼干。哦，我想我们家里有一些。我儿子买的。超棒。我儿子想吃。千万别吃一个。除非你想吃光整整一盒，否则一个也别碰。
I don't want to. But that's what I eat, and then all I have at the end of the day is like three sentences and a stomach ache. Before we move into our next section, do you have any other memories from your time on the set? I had the greatest time. I got to improvise and wander around. Do whatever you want. Do whatever you want. I mean, it's just an amazing thing to be invited to do. Of course, you're hoping you're actually being funny, but they can cut it if you're not. Um... Um... Um...
我才不想呢。但我吃的就是这些，到了最后，我一整天下来也就写出了三句话，还落了个胃疼。在我们进入下一个环节之前，你在片场期间还有什么其他回忆吗？我度过了一段最棒的时光。我能够即兴发挥，四处闲逛。想做什么就做什么。想做什么就做什么。我是说，能被邀请去参与其中简直是一件太不可思议的事了。当然，你内心希望自己实际上挺搞笑的，不过如果不够好，他们也可以把镜头剪掉。呃……呃……呃……
I know it's not a memory of being on set. I loved it, Jenna. Thank you for doing it with me, you know, and and thank you to Greg Daniels and Jon Favreau and everybody in your crew and cast because I felt very welcome there. I think people think everyone in Hollywood is in a rivalry. And that's true of a lot of what we do. But not everything. I mean, I was very happy that I got to audition for the show. Totally fine and completely understood that I was not the right person for that role.
我知道这算不上什么片场回忆。我真的很喜欢，珍娜。谢谢你陪我一起经历这些，你知道的，也谢谢格雷格·丹尼尔斯、乔恩·费儒以及你们剧组和演员阵容里的每一个人，因为我在那儿感觉非常受欢迎。我觉得人们总以为好莱坞里的每个人都在尔虞我诈、互相竞争。我们所做的事里确实有很多是这样的。但并非全部。我是说，我当时能去为这部剧试镜，我真的感到非常开心。而且我也完全能够理解并欣然接受我并不适合那个角色。
And super thrilled that Steve... I actually don't know Steve. I feel like I might have met him. You and Steve don't like really know each other? Yeah, I might have met him once or twice. Like a passing thing. Isn't that weird? Yeah. Yeah. It's really weird, cause he's a second city guy too.
并且超级为史蒂芬感到高兴……其实我不认识史蒂芬。我觉得我可能曾经见过他。你和史蒂芬其实并不怎么认识对方？对啊，我大概在一两次场合里见过他吧。就那种点头之交。不是很奇怪吗？对啊。对啊。真的很奇怪，因为他也是个来自“第二城”（Second City）的人。
Yeah. I mean, it's very weird. Him and Tim Meadows, that whole group. Oh yeah, and I'm super close to Tim, you know? But, you know, I never had anything but enjoyment that this show was happening and it was being so accepted and that all these wonderful actors got to have a showcase, like really show what they could do. When you live out here and you work here, one of the hardest things is, and when you direct
对。我是说，这非常奇怪。他和蒂姆·梅多斯，还有他们整个那个团体。哦对，我和蒂姆超级熟的，你知道的？但是，你知道的，对于这部剧能够问世、大受欢迎，以及所有这些优秀的演员能够拥有一个展示的舞台、真正展现他们的才华，我除了感到高兴之外，从来没有过别的任何情绪。当你住在这个城市并且在这里工作时，最难的事情之一就是，当你当导演时，
and you have people come in and audition, I mean, I always tell young actors, you know, you probably do too. I'm sure your book says something about try to work for a casting director once, because what you're going to see is you're going to see those auditions and what you're going to see is not that one person was amazing and everyone else sucked. Most of the time you're going to see that if 60 people auditioned, 15 of them were good, you know, 10 were really good, five, everyone was amazing. And you're gonna realize one of those five
你让人们进来试镜，我是说，我总是告诉年轻演员，你知道的，你大概也是这么做的。我确信你的书里也提到过，试着去为选角导演工作一次，因为你将会看到的是，你会看到那些试镜，而你所看到的并不是某一个人惊为天人而其他人全都是垃圾。大多数时候你会看到，如果有60个人来试镜，其中15个人都很不错，你知道的，10个人真的非常棒，5个人，每个人都惊艳无比。然后你会意识到这五个人当中的某一个
is gonna get the role and the other four who were unbelievably awesome are gonna think I sucked. I'm not good enough. And they're wrong, they're wrong. They didn't get the part because they didn't match up with the other person who got the other part. And we've already got a person with that kind of energy. Now, you know, it had nothing to do. They were amazing. So it's heartbreaking, though, to have that awareness.
将会得到这个角色，而另外四个明明好得令人难以置信的人却会觉得自己“我太逊了，我根本不够好”。而他们大错特错，他们完全错了。他们没能得到这个角色，只是因为他们与已经拿到另一个角色的演员不够搭。我们已经有一个那种类型的能量的人了。所以，你知道的，这根本没关系。他们表现得太棒了。因此，产生这种认知其实是件很让人心碎的事。
Because you're very aware that, like, there's people walking around thinking, well, I thought I was an actor. I thought I was pretty good, but I didn't get these roles. But you want to say, no, no, you were, you really were great. That's such good advice for the new actor. Or the old actor. Okay, we are going to wrap up this interview, Bob, which has been so wonderful. For a yammered forever. No, you didn't. We wanted you to yammer, which has been so wonderful. Before I yammered forever.
因为你清醒地意识到，有些人到处走动，心里却在想：“好吧，我以为我算是个演员呢。我以为我演技还挺不错的，但我偏偏没拿到这些角色。”但你真想对他们说：“不，不，你真的很棒，你真的非常优秀。”这对新演员来说真是个极好的建议。对老演员也是如此。好了，鲍勃，我们要结束这次访谈了，这次聊得太棒了。因为我喋喋不休了半天。不，你才没有。我们就是想让你喋喋不休，这次访谈真的太棒了。在我喋喋不休了半天之前。
No, you didn't. We wanted you to yammer. We love a yammer. We yammer. So, you know, we look at all the call sheets from our years on The Office, and on the back of our call sheets, there was a really fun tradition where each week a cast or crew member was featured, and they were asked five questions. So we'd like to ask you our call sheet questions.
不，你才没有。我们就是想让你喋喋不休。我们就喜欢听人喋喋不休。我们自己也会喋喋不休。所以，你知道的，我们回顾了我们在《办公室》度过的那些年里的所有通告单（call sheet），在通告单的背面有一个非常有趣的传统，那就是每周都会介绍一位演员或剧组工作人员，并向他们提出五个问题。所以我们也想问你我们的通告单问题。
Oh, yeah, I want to hear it. Okay. Number one, what was your first entertainment job? Oh, uh, it's embarrassing. Say it! I'm pretty sure this is what it is. Oh no, I'm going to tell you. Okay. A guy had a bar. It was like a singles bar.
哦，好的，我洗耳恭听。好的。第一题，你的第一份演艺工作是什么？哦，呃，这挺尴尬的。说出来听听！我挺确定答案就是这个。哦不，我得告诉你。好吧。有个家伙开了一家酒吧。有点像那种单身酒吧。
And he hired me and another person to play characters in the bar. And walk around and engage with people. Really? That is great. It was dumb as. F***. Did you take on like a persona? Oh, I had costumes and everything.
他雇我和另一个人去酒吧里扮演角色。四处走动，跟人搭讪。真的吗？那太棒了。蠢透了。特么的。你当时是扮演某种特定的人设吗？哦，我甚至有戏服和各种行头。
Oh my God. I did it like three times. It was super embarrassing, but you know, you know when you start, you don't know what you're doing or why. Somebody's paying you to act. Was he just trying to like drum up business and make it like a fun spot by having interesting folks? Yeah, yeah. So dumb, so embarrassing. All right. Number two, do you speak any other languages?
噢天哪。我大概干了三次。超级尴尬，不过你知道的，刚入行的时候，你根本不知道自己在做什么，也不知道为什么要这么做。反正有人付钱让你去表演。他是不是只是想招揽顾客，通过安排一些有趣的人来把这里变成一个好玩的地方？对啊，对啊。太蠢了，太尴尬了。好吧。第二题，你会说其他语言吗？
No. I barely speak English. Number three, what's a place that you've been to that you absolutely loved? Ireland, Kenmare and around the environment, the environs, the area down there in the Southwest. I've been there a couple of times in the last few years and it really is the best. I love it. Yeah. What made you go there in the first place?
不会。我连英语都快说不利落了。第三题，你曾经去过什么地方，并且绝对爱上了那里？爱尔兰，肯梅尔以及周边的环境、郊区，还有西南部的那片区域。过去几年我去了好几次，那里真的是最棒的。我太爱了。是的。是什么让你最初去那里的？
Well, I love Ireland and I used to go there when I wrote at Saturday Night Live. I would go there once a year because it was relatively quick and you know, we'd have two weeks off and you just get on a plane in New York and be in Shannon in five and a half hours. It's shorter than LA, depending on the wind. And it's just the opposite of the life I was living in New York. I'd wander around and play golf and just kind of drive around. Beautiful countryside. So then many years would by and Naomi and I visited there.
嗯，我太喜欢爱尔兰了，以前我在《周六夜现场》写剧本的时候就经常去那里。我一年会去一次，因为路程相对较快，而且你知道的，我们有两周的假期，你只要在纽约登上一架飞机，五个半小时就能到达香农。比去洛杉矶短，取决于风向。而且那里的生活节奏跟我当时在纽约过的生活截然相反。我会四处闲逛，打打高尔夫球，到处开车兜风。美丽的乡村风光。后来很多年过去了，娜奥米和我去那里旅游了。
Then we had kids, then no trips anywhere for a long time. Yep. And I really wanted to get back and I went back about two and a half years ago with Naomi and my kids and we spent about a week there. And I went a couple times for my books. And then last summer, I was like, I really haven't had the chance to just hang out there in a long time.
然后我们有了孩子，接着很长一段时间都没去任何地方旅行。没错。我真的很想再次回去，大约两年半前我和娜奥米还有我的孩子们一起回去了，我们在那里呆了一周左右。为了我的书我也去过几次。然后去年夏天，我在想，我真的好久没有机会纯粹去那里闲逛了。
So I split off from Naomi and I went back to Ireland. And I actually went back to where we had already been because we were doing that traveling thing that you do of like, you know, going to Dublin for two days. It's like, well, you're not really, yes, you're seeing Dublin, but not really. You're there for two days. Yeah. You know, so I went and Kenmare is just great town that is kind of hip. It's kind of got some really great food in it and stuff and small town. And it's down there around, you know, Kerry, the Ring of Kerry and Bantry Bay is right there.
所以我跟娜奥米分头行动，自己回到了爱尔兰。其实我回到了我们去过的地方，因为我们当时在进行那种你也会干的旅游活动，你知道的，比如去都柏林待两天。这就好像，嗯，你其实不是，是的，你确实看到了都柏林，但并不是真的看到了。你在那儿就待两天。对啊。你知道的，所以我去了，肯梅尔真的是个很棒的小镇，很有时尚气息。那里有一些非常棒的美食之类的，而且是个小镇。它就在周围，你知道的，凯里，凯里的环形公路（Ring of Kerry），班特里湾（Bantry Bay）就在旁边。
And, you know, you can get around pretty easily. And so I went back there and stayed for a week and a half and just hiked around. And I went up to Sligo and I went around. There's a number of towns that I used to go to when I was younger and I go back. And I can't wait to go back again. Do you think it's the place you've been to the most in your life? Uh-huh. Yeah, it is. Is it your happy place? Would you say it's your happy place? Absolutely. Yeah.
而且，你知道的，出行非常方便。所以我又回到了那里，呆了一个半星期，到处徒步旅行。我还去了斯莱戈（Sligo）转了转。有很多小镇是我年轻时经常去的，我都会再去看看。我迫不及待想再去一次。你觉得这是你一生中去过次数最多的地方吗？嗯哼。对，是的。那是你的快乐老家吗？你会说那是你的快乐老家吗？绝对是。对。
Yeah. I mean, a lot of people love Ireland. It's weird when you talk about Ireland, you're like, you just sound so corny because you've heard it. Everything you're saying has been said by other people so much. You know, it's a really beautiful place. It is also, can be very cold and rainy. Yes, this is true. This is true. Okay, next question. What do you like to do on the weekends? Oh, I'm pretty boring. And Naomi and I have been making an effort to be a great deal more social than we've been for 20 years. So we try to find people to go to dinner with and stuff, you know,
对啊。我是说，很多人都喜欢爱尔兰。说起爱尔兰时感觉挺奇怪的，你会觉得自己听上去好老套，因为这些话你都听过。你说的每一句话都被其他人翻来覆去说过无数遍了。你知道的，那真的是个非常美丽的地方。不过，那里也可能会非常寒冷和多雨。是的，这倒真的。确实如此。好吧，下一个问题。你周末喜欢做些什么？哦，我挺无聊的。我和娜奥米一直在努力变得比过去20年里更加社牛、更有社交活动一点。所以我们尝试找人一起吃晚饭之类的，你知道的，
usually other people in the biz. That's who our friends are. But I wake up, walk my dog, which I do every morning, probably write or do a workout, have lunch, write or do a workout. So both those things happen either in the morning or in the afternoon. I've grown to like working out because of the feature that I made, the action movie, and sort of what I learned about exercise. So I do enjoy it. I'm gonna go do a workout after this.
通常是圈内其他人。我们的朋友都是这些同行。但我醒来后会去遛狗，我每天早上都这么做，可能会写写作或者健健身，然后吃午餐，接着再写写作或者健健身。所以这两件事要么在早上发生，要么在下午发生。由于我拍的那部动作片，我逐渐开始喜欢上了健身，也从中学到了很多关于锻炼的知识。所以我确实挺享受的。访谈结束后我就要去健健身。
Love it. And then try to figure out where to get some awesome dinner. And if there's a show we haven't watched, we just finished watching Baby Reindeer. Have you seen it? No. Have you seen it, Jenna? No, we just finished Ripley. We just finished The New Look. Did you enjoy it? I loved Ripley.
太棒了。然后琢磨着去哪吃顿超赞的晚饭。如果有什么我们还没看过剧，我们刚刚看完《驯鹿宝贝》。你看过吗？没有。詹娜你看过吗？没有，我们刚看完《雷普利》。我们刚看完《新风貌》（The New Look）。你觉得好看吗？我超爱《雷普利》。
I love the actor, the hot priest. Hot priest. Yeah. Oh, yes. Hot priest from Sleeveye. Yes, I know. He has a name. It's Andrew Scott.
我超爱那个演员，那个性感神父。性感神父。对啊。哦，是的。来自《伦敦生活》的性感神父。是的，我知道。他有名字的。叫安德鲁·斯科特（Andrew Scott）。
And yes, we should call him that. We should. Although I believe he must forgive you if you address him as hot priest. It was fantastic. We loved it. Oh, great. And then I just, I got on an Andrew Scott kick and then I watched all of us strangers. Beautiful.
对的，我们应该这么叫他。必须的。尽管我相信如果你称呼他为性感神父，他一定会原谅你的。真的太棒了。我们爱死这部剧了。哦，太好了。然后我，我迷上了安德鲁·斯科特，接着我就把《我们异乡人》全看完了。太美了。
Beautiful. That's great. Baby reindeer is really great. Okay. And really, it's intense. Really intense. All right. Okay.
太美了。那太棒了。真的，\\《驯鹿宝贝》非常棒。好的。而且真的很，情节非常紧凑。真的非常紧凑。好吧。好吧。
I'll put it on the list. Yeah. I'll check it out. My husband and I are watching The New Look. You know who loves The New Look is Creed. Creed Braddy? Creed told me to watch The New Look. The New Look.
我把它加入片单。好的。我会去看的。我丈夫和我正在看《新风貌》。你知道谁喜欢《新风貌》吗？是克里德。克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratten）？克里德让我去看《新风貌》。《新风貌》。
The New Look. Who is it? It's about Coco Chanel. Do they act it out or is it a documentary? No, no, it's scripted. It's scripted and it's shot during World War II. During the Nazi occupation of France. France and it's about Christian Dior.
《新风貌》。讲的是谁的？是关于可可·香奈儿的。这是真人演的还是纪录片？不，不，这是有剧本的。是有剧本的剧情片，而且背景设定在二战期间。在纳粹占领法国期间。法国，而且讲的是克里斯汀·迪奥。
Get out of town. Yes. And Coco Chanel. And Coco Chanel. And I'm totally in. Is he crazy? I'm hooked, I'm in, yeah. Well, I don't know. I mean, that sounds like. I'm hooked. I'm in, yeah. Yeah. Well, I don't know.
开什么玩笑。是的。还有可可·香奈儿。还有可可·香奈儿。那我绝对要看。他是不是疯了？我入坑了，我看了，对。嗯，我不知道。我是说，听起来就像。我入坑了。我看了，对。对啊。嗯，我不知道。
I mean, that sounds like nothing I would watch. Okay. Last question. Favorite midnight snack? Oh, I don't eat at night. Come on. Can't do that. I'm 61 years old.
我是说，听起来完全不是我会看的那类剧。好吧。最后一个问题。最喜欢的午夜小吃？哦，我晚上不吃东西。拜托。我可做不到。我都61岁了。
Well, done. Yeah. I applaud that. Yeah, I'm in bed at midnight. I don't eat anything at midnight. Oh man, I'm in bed. Yeah. I'm gone.
干得漂亮。对啊。我为这番话点赞。对啊，我午夜时分已经上床睡觉了。我午夜绝不吃任何东西。噢天哪，我已经上床了。对啊。我早就睡着了。
What is your bedtime at this age? 10? 10? 10? Yeah, I applaud that. Yeah, I'm in bed at midnight. I don't eat anything at midnight. Oh, man, I'm in bed. Yeah. I'm gone. What is your bedtime at this age? 10? 1030? I can't stay up that late. My bedtime is 9.
你在这个年纪的就寝时间是几点？10点？10点半？对啊，我为这番话点赞。对啊，我午夜时分已经上床睡觉了。我午夜绝不吃任何东西。噢天哪，我已经上床了。对啊。我早就睡着了。你在这个年纪的就寝时间是几点？10点？10点半？我可熬不了那么晚。我的就寝时间是9点。
1030. I'm 1030. I'm moseying up. I'm in bed at 9, and my lights are out by 930. Yeah. I can't go to the, if you want to have dinner with me, we need to eat like when the restaurant's opening. Like at 530 is not too early for me.
10点半。我大概10点半。我会慢悠悠地上楼。我9点钟就在床上躺着了，9点半灯就全关了。对啊。我可去不了，如果你想跟我吃晚饭，我们得赶在餐馆刚开门的时候吃。比如傍晚5点半对我来说一点都不算早。
Listen, that's what we do. I'm with those people. Jenna, I'm always telling my wife, can we please get a five o'clock reservation? Some restaurants don't open until 530, but Bob, I have a list of five o'clockers if you need them. But the thing is, who wants all that food in their old person's stomach? Belly at night. When they're trying to fall asleep.
听着，我们就是这样。我和这类人是一伙的。詹娜，我总是跟我妻子说：我们能订一个5点的位子吗？有些餐馆直到5点半才开门，不过鲍勃，如果你需要的话，我这里有一份“5点党”餐馆名单。但关键是，谁想在自己老年人的肚子里塞那么多食物呢？晚上吃宵夜。当他们正试图入睡的时候。
No one. My husband loves to eat at five, five thirty. And I've had conversation with my friends I call my sexy friends, who like go out at like eight o'clock to eat or something or nine o'clock. They'll say like, oh, it's impossible to get a reservation of that restaurant. I'm like, we've never had a problem. Because if you go at 515, there's the table. There is. Absolutely.
没人想这样。我丈夫就喜欢在5点、5点半吃晚饭。我还跟我那些被称为“性感辣妈”的朋友们聊过天，她们喜欢在晚上8点或者9点左右出去吃饭什么的。她们会说：“天哪，那家餐厅根本订不到位子。”而我会说：“我们从来没遇到过问题。”因为如果你在5点15分去，位子绝对是有的。确实如此。绝对的。
Thank you so much, Bob. See you guys at dinner at five o'clock. Bob, this was awesome. Thank you. Thank you. Thanks for letting me talk and talk and talk. I like to talk. Well, I like to talk about showbiz.
非常感谢你，鲍勃。回头发微信看5点钟的晚餐怎么安排。鲍勃，这次太棒了。谢谢你。谢谢。谢谢你们让我说个没完没了。我这人就喜欢聊天。不过我也喜欢聊演艺圈的事。
I like your thoughts on showbiz. I did too. Yeah. It's fun. This was wonderful. Yeah. Okay. Thank you. Go enjoy your workout.
我也很喜欢你对演艺圈的看法。我也是。对啊。挺好玩的。这次访谈太棒了。对啊。好的。谢谢你。快去享受你的健身吧。
How great was Bob? Amazing. I mean, gosh, Bob, thank you so much for stopping by office, ladies. Now during the interview, everybody, Bob mentioned his books, and you should definitely check them out. He recently wrote a memoir called Comedy, Comedy, Comedy, Drama, a memoir, and he also published Xylot and Other Important Rhymes.
鲍勃刚才表现得有多棒？太惊艳了。我是说，天哪，鲍勃，非常感谢你光临《办公室女士》。好了，在访谈期间，各位听众，鲍勃提到了他的书，你们绝对应该去读一读。他最近写了一部回忆录，名叫《喜剧，喜剧，喜剧，戏剧：回忆录》（Comedy, Comedy, Comedy, Drama: A Memoir），他还出版了一部名为《木琴及其他重要童谣》（Zylot and Other Important Rhymes）的作品。
That is a book of, like, it's like whimsical poetry. It's for people of all ages. His daughter, Erin Odenkirk, illustrated it. I might have written a blurb for it, everyone. Yes, but they are poems that are based on a book of poems that he wrote for his kids when they were little. And he would read them at bedtime. And it's really fun.
那是一本充满奇思妙想的诗集。适合所有年龄段的读者。他的女儿艾琳·奥登柯克（Erin Odenkirk）为它画了插图。我可能还为它写过书评呢，各位。是的，不过这些诗都是基于他以前在孩子们还小的时候写给他们的诗集改编的。他会在孩子们睡觉前读给他们听。真的非常有趣。
It reminded me of like Shel Silverstein. That's probably my best comparison. Also, the action movie he talked about is called Nobody, and it's currently streaming on Amazon Prime. And we'll share links to that and everything else in our pod stories. Thanks, everyone, for listening. And thanks, Bob.
这让我想起了谢尔·希尔弗斯坦（Shel Silverstein）的作品。这大概是我能想到的最好的对比了。另外，他提到的那部动作片名叫《小人物》（Nobody），目前正在亚马逊Prime Video上热播。我们会在节目简介中分享这部电影以及其他所有内容的链接。谢谢大家收听。也谢谢鲍勃。
Yeah, we hope you guys have a great week. ["The Office Ladies"] Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fischer, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Jordan Duffy. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco.
对啊，希望大家都能度过美好的一周。["办公室女士"] 感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是乔丹·达菲。我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿演奏的《橡胶树》。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击节目文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。